عوده حركه السوترات الصفر في فرنسا الى
الشارع لكن هذه المره مسلحه بغضب شعبيه
يتصاعد على تدهور الاوضاع المعيشيه في ظل
سياق سياسيا فرضته تداعيات الحرب
الاوكرانيه
بضع مئات تظاهر في شوارع العاصمه معلنين
انطلاق الحركه الاحتجاجيه للعام الجديد
ومنددين باوضاع معيشيه الصعبه وتلك ان
حكوميه في معالجتها
لكن الحكومه هنا من اجل هدمه لن ننخدع
وسنكون حاسمين حتى لو لم تكن اعدادنا
كبيره في وجه هذه الاتهامات تدافع الحكومه
بالقول ان السياق الذي تشهده التظاهرات
الان مختلف عن ما كان عليه الحال عند
ولاده حركه السترات الصفر عام 2018
المتحدث باسم الحكومه يقول ان نسبه
البطاله خفضت والحد الادنى للاجور ارتفع
لكن بالنسبه للبعض هي ادعاءات بعيده عن
الواقع
لم نعد نملك شيئا واكثر من ذلك في بلد
الديمقراطيه والحريه وحقوق الانسان يجب ان
تقوم بتصوير الشرطه كيف تحيط بالمتظاهرين
مع المتظاهرين حيث لم يسمح لاحد منهم
بالخروج عن مسار التظاهره وسارت قوات
الشرطه معهم كتفا لكتف منعا لحدوث اعمال
شغب طاغت على المشهد الاحتجاج طيله
السنوات السابقه فايده العربيه باريس